l'arrivée ou la nonne arrivée d'un prêt
jamais jamais n'a changé un iota de la
position et des idées qui étaient les
nôtres en matière géopolitique je vous
le dis je vous l'affirme et je vous le
dis avec d'autant plus de fermeté que
j'ai souffert
d'une campagne de diffamation absolument
inadmissible depuis un certain nombre
d'années
[Musique]
personne n'ignorait que nous n'avions
aucune possibilité
d'obtenir un prêt ni en France ni dans
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne je
signais après avec une banque je signe
pas après que Vladimir Poutine
voilà sinon tous vous avez signé des
prêts avec Macron ça ne m'engage
absolument à rien et si ça m'avait
engagé à quelque chose monsieur le
Président je n'aurais pas signé ce prêt
c'est clair je ne l'aurais pas signé car
jamais personne monsieur le Président ne
m'a jamais rien demandé en contrepartie
de quoi que ce soit alors j'ai peut-être
de la chance j'ai jamais été victime ne
serait-ce qu'une tentative d'ingérence
peut-être que les gens connaissent mon
caractère peut-être que ma réputation me
précède c'est possible d'accord mais
vous avez quand même conscience que
cette banque est été dirigée par un
proche du pouvoir russe et que Monsieur
chauffeur lui-même nous a dit lors de la
dernière audition que jamais cette
banque n'aurait fait se prêt sans la
corde monsieur Poutine mais d'abord un
ça n'est pas exactement la même chose et
deux je n'en s'abais absolument rien
mais rien pourquoi voulez-vous que je le
sache monsieur chafouzer qui vous occupe
moi après il me trouve un prêt il me
ramène un prêt je le signe et je suis
très content je peux vous dire parce que
c'était ça ou la mort de votre question
mais pourquoi je me poserais une
question monsieur le Président dites moi
pourquoi me poserais une question voilà
des fonds dans la provenance sont
vérifiées par la Société Générale
qui doit être elle qui doit demander
l'autorisation je suppose à Monsieur
Macron avant de faire la moindre
opération bon si j'en crois ce que vous
dites de la liberté des banques à agir
dans les différents pays
surveiller non mais attendez pardon
surveillé par nos commissaires aux
comptes surveiller par Tracfin
surveiller par la CNCCFP si un seul de
ces organismes était venu me voir en me
disant il y a un problème sur l'origine
des fonds marines je pense que il est
dangereux de signer ce prêt je ne
l'aurais pas signé mais tout cela s'est
fait encore une fois dans des conditions
absolument totale de transparence et non
monsieur le Président je ne me suis pas
posé la question de savoir si le
président de la banque était ou
connaissait où était un proche de
Vladimir Poutine et objectivement je ne
sais ce que j'aurais fait de cette
information dont je me moquais et
perdument
dont je me moquais éperdument compte
tenu de l'importance encore une fois et
de la la joie que nous avions d'avoir
réussi à trouver un prêt au moment où
notre mouvement en avait si besoin